pour le moment les séries on va jouer à
zobi la mouche
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que c'est que ça la bouche est
ce que vous voulez
[Applaudissements]
et
vers sa famille l'a vu ce qu'est ce
qu'ils font
the bee la bouche il faut des mouches et
maintenant il faut sopi c'est pour ça
que j'ai perdu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le gag
il vient déjà de mateur vous créé tout
seul billet dans une fiction comment ça
va moins bien c'est le traître r6 d'être
là merci d'être là je suis très content
de soja alors on dépense est prévu un
jeu ce sont la grammaire selon ton grave
mais justement tu vas nous d'expliquer
monsieur alors les chéris vous allez
démarrer à chaque fois vous allez donner
donc c'est quoi ce qu'un proverbe avec
le mot mouche dedans vous jouez
également s'ils sont vous êtes tous en
mouche celui qui répondra mal se prendra
un coup deux jeux vous donc de
définition qui vous permettent de
trouver des expressions 1 figure le mot
mouche accord attention ça va aller très
vite
nicolas pernikoff ancien patron de
france télévisions un exemple doivent
d'abord vedettes n'ont pas la prétention
tirer avec précision sur ces précisions
ont dit on diffère faire c'est fini
c'est tout
c'est ok bravo vous y allez un set est
resté calme et vous au congrès cision
les mouches
il faut que ce soit et bien la phrase
payer celle qui est accepté il faut pas
fumer crée qui ne font mouche à les
attentions
bernard desprez ouais non se vexer se
fâcher lesquelles assange rang deux et
notre ordre l'amour c'est rare est allé
à bouffe attention tes pattes être
inactif prendre parce qu'on connaîtra
des périodes de temps à rêvasser alors
et basson durant laquelle une bonne
concentration
j maigrichonne chanté par pierre perret
cuisse de mouchoirs et et l'hydratation
je peux aller série attention je vous
rappelle le principe si vous nous
rejoignez on est en direct faut trouver
des expressions avec le mot mouche
accord calmez-vous un petit peu d'accord
calmez-vous pas vraiment les dodos
attention très cool non violent paisible
on dit oh il ne fera pas de mal à une
mouche
[Applaudissements]
les passions fait chaud à paris match
aller
[Applaudissements]
et moi et moi cette [ __ ] besoins de
demain et d'assez que j'arrête
j'arrête pour le mental aimant ce jeu
pour lancer coin flow donnent l'exemple
si je ne serai pas refaire les chéris
allez-y c'est parti mais j'ai classé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une manif alors doucement à la [ __ ]
attention fragile il peut taper un nom
pas trop quand on est mal luné on est
grognon
on est bougon omri avec quelle quelle
mouche l'a piqué à bisous bisous
alors elle a avec la bousculade fait
tousser il n'est pas si kenny trou soit
interdit à ma mère chemin ex l'eau avec
jean pierre descombes maîtrise ya des
doutes en fait la resega les matins des
caennais doute prédit marvel va trouver
du pétrole
cctv qui allie machine aux halles on est
tous les deux dans un endroit tranquille
après ça il ya personne et tout d'un
coup tout est vêtu me dit jean-pierre on
entend pas
[Applaudissements]
vidéo s'est uni vos journaux quel
silence on encore y aller tu en avais tu
viens de la sphère écriture fine et peu
lisible on dit que c'est une balle de
mouches l'animateur maladie la soeur
ouais le vendredi il me semble il voit
tu m'as fait 800 matches où vas tu vas
prendre 800 mille aussi de dommages d'un
territoire à l'essai par je suis prêt
oliva mais sa couleur
oui mais tu es bien
oh la la c'est une personnalité qui est
très rusé a dit que c'est une âme et
annoncé que c'est pas toi ça tu sais
c'est une ironie c'est une sabri
lamouchi itunes
c'est une menace qui je vous le dis
alors vous savez quoi
si benhaim trouve va trouver jimena
improve on arrête je trouve
ah ouais enfin snow et on se trouve face
mois ses fils j'aimerais pense qu'on
peut passer tout tu t'en vas pas su tuer
un match
non mais attends mathieu attention à la
baisse en trois mois
il faut lui faire mon attention celle-ci
n est un moment de télé celle-ci mathieu
toi fou je suis très heureux qu'elle
tombe sur toi mathieu aussi aller pas
facile une personne qui fait attention à
des détails de faible importance les
petites et après je pars aux 10 11 et
andy c'est un nom c'est bon mais alors
s'il est un fait ça c'est assez puni
fait les trois secondes rosa de doha
c'est pourquoi c'est un métier lui le
coup d'avant
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'attendais
pour nous c'est la manche savoie la
nature jean-pierre c'est bon mais un
jour soit qu'on a plus
[Applaudissements]